No the world isn’t literally shrinking,
but for humans, it kinda is.
Up until 500 years ago, nobody had even ever
circumnavigated the globe, but nowadays, anybody
can do this in a couple days just by paying
a couple thousand dollars.
Therefore, in the perspective of today’s
humans, the world is much smaller than it
used to be.
In the time that it took for the first circumnavigation
of the world, today’s humans could fly to
Mars and back twice.
Think about this, to today’s human, the
moon seems significantly closer than America
seemed to Europeans in the 16th century when
the first voyages departed.
It only takes humans 3 days to go the moon,
verses over two month’s for the colonists
to go to America.
Up until 1693, nobody had ever been able to
circumnavigate the globe as a “tourist”,
as in paying for their own transit on public
transport.
Gemelli Careri was the first person to do
this feat, and it took him 5 years.
David Springbett has the current record for
this accomplishment with his journey from
Los Angeles, to London, to Bahrein, to Singapore,
to Bangkok, to Manila, to Tokyo, to Honolulu,
then back to Los Angeles in 44 hours and six
minutes.
In 1800, you couldn’t even get from New
York to DC in those 44 hours.
Between the years of 1857 and 1930, the time
it took to cross the United States went from
about three or four weeks to one day.
Not only has the time of travel plummeted,
the accessibility has too.
46% of American’s will travel outside of
the US in their lifetime.
Adjusted for inflation, the average cost of
domestic air travel in the US has dropped
by more than 50% in just the last 30 years.
50 years ago, only 20% of Americans had ever
flown in an airplane, but today, only 20%
haven’t.
In some ways this may be saddening.
There is less to explore.
There are pretty much no places left on earth
that are inaccessible to the average human
being.
One can travel to every continent, every ocean,
every country with relative ease.
However, this does mean that practically anyone
with the thirst for adventure can visit every
continent, ocean, or country.
In the coming years, we will have even more
to explore, as we look up to the stars, and
leave earth.
We can already buy our tickets to go to outer
space, and although it might not feasible
for the everyday human to buy their ticket
now, just look how fast the price of air travel
plummeted.
By the end of our lifetimes, going to the
moon might just be as easy as flying to Europe.